Josh let's just get right into the news
from yesterday first one I guess I'll
hit you up on is Reuben Foster the
outstanding linebacker from Alabama
there was evidently already some all
field concerns then he got kicked out of
the combine for yelling at the people
over at the hospital because he was
frustrated waiting for an MRI now it
comes out he tells NFL media that he
tested positive for a diluted sample
which is the same as a positive test at
what point are we concerned about this
guy Josh and at what point do we think
this starts to really hurt him any falls
down the draft board I think teams are
still thinking that our office in fact I
know of three teams who are visiting
with him this weekend sending a few
members of their staff down to you know
kind of get a final feel for him and
then come back and discuss them some
more on Monday I've heard from a number
of people that Reuben Foster is a top
two talent on the field that's what his
tape is I mean when you watch him or
else he's an absolute missile at the
second level he's a really really good
player and I thought before this may be
the latest he could be on the board
would be 11 to the saints or the Ravens
but now we've seen it the number times
in the past with talented prospects like
you know Telvin Smith for example Randy
Gregory each case is individual but I
could absolutely see Reuben Foster still
stay in the top 15 or fall outside the
top 32 yeah and most people will tell
you he's one of the two or three best
players in this draft he's really good I
mean and and there was a I think he did
a piece with the mmqb is Robert Clem co
and Clem Co talked about how some teams
had some frustration with them in terms
of how he acted on the whiteboard and
being able to diagnose place but then I
mean frost you know you can't play and
star in Nick Saban's defense if you
don't know the defense right and so
anytime actual film was up there he's
actually on the field I mean there is no
hesitation to his game I think he's a
plug-and-play starter immediately at the
second level both in the running game in
the passing game tongue with josh norris
the NFL draft writer for NBC
sports he was interesting for me Josh
got to imagine that there are some teams
that have the same mindset but for any
of these guys anyone situation typically
I can live with but as soon as there's a
second one that's when I really really
get concerned like even the joe mix and
stuff that came out recently where there
was this report back in in high school
that a dad said that he had assaulted
his daughter and then the dad later
recanted it there's nothing on his
record none of that stuff but obviously
we've all seen the video of the day
after his 18th birthday when he hit the
girl at Oklahoma but to me Josh even the
fact that the father posted what he
posted on facebook when Joe Mixon was in
high school that is extremely troubling
because even if you later recanted it's
still now a second situation in the same
realm of conversation in terms of
behavior well and it's it's new
information that teams will have to
respond to an answer to if they should
add them I mean we hear it all the time
and see it all the time with these
prospects that something is made a big
deal in december and january i mean i'll
give you this example Leonard fournette
and Christian McCaffrey you know sitting
out there teams bowl games or schools
bowl games when was the last time we
talked about that in this draft process
but we get over a lot of these things
just because of the recent information i
also want to get into some of the
comments recently by Deshawn Kaiser the
nur dame quarterback it's in the USA
Today article I mean he went you know
I'm gonna read you the money that the
money quotes ok name a college
quarterback who goes in the game plan
meetings on monday and throws his notes
at the coaches no one else game plans
the way I do no one else prepares the
way I do no one else can do what I can
do and I've truly figured out in this
process if I can maximize all my
potential in every aspect of the game
this is bold I do have the ability to be
the greatest quarterback to ever play
and
imagine taking Brady's intellect and
Bradys preparation and putting it on a
guy with Cam Newton's body why can't I
do the greatest the only thing stopping
me from it is me that's what's driving
me now end quote so your reaction to
that quote Josh okay usually I'm not
into all this like self-appreciation
stuff but Ross I love this because if
his head coach isn't going to do it for
him why not do it for yourself like I
think the things that Brian Kelly said
about DeSean Kaiser was extremely unfair
even if it might be honest I think it's
extremely unfair during this draft
process because look what just as
counterpart in Davos Sweeney and deshaun
Watson how he's describing to Shawn
Watson during this draft process calling
him the Michael Jordan of football and
things like that meanwhile Brian Kelly's
out there and Ross to me with with what
Kelly's comments are publicly it just
makes me question what he's saying
privately as well and then the fact that
Kelly's going to the draft is just quote
unquote support DeSean Kaiser give me a
break but but Kaiser is someone who I
think Ross 2015 DeSean Kaiser is the
best quarterback tape out there in this
class you look at what he did stepping
up as a 19 year old as a third string
quarterback in spring practices stepping
in early in the season finding open
receivers in terms of handling pressure
in the pocket keeping his eyes up again
I can't answer to as why his 2016 stuff
is not nearly as good as 2015 but again
if there's one quarterback that I want
in this class it's 2015 to Shawn Kaiser
so here's the thing I don't understand
we're talking with josh norris the NBC
Sports NFL draft writer here on the Dan
Patrick show when all the initial mock
drafts came out yeah all the initial
rankings came out everybody had to shun
Kaiser as one of the top one two maybe
three quarterbacks maybe three but a lot
of mock drafts he's going in the top ten
a lot of rankings he was the number one
quarterback Patrick mahomes from Texas
Tech
was fourth or fifth in most of the
rankings every once a while maybe you
found them going like pick number 30 or
something but usually was high second
round here we are a couple months later
and mind you Josh neither one of these
guys have actually played in a football
game and now DeSean Kaiser is talked
about like he's the fourth or fifth
quarterback and Pat mahomes people might
think might go in the top ten how does
that happen that people are changing
their rankings and they're charging
their mock drafts and everything that
much since the last time you guys
actually played football so one I can
only speak for myself and I've had
kaisers top quarterback since December
okay but to I think you have to realize
or think about what has happened since
then in the last month in the last month
has been the pro day process in terms of
executives and position coaches being on
the trail and a lot of big draft media
has been attending these pro days and
talking to these coaches and everything
and I think all those comments are all
sweat what you just read of Kaiser you
can tell that Kaiser is an individual
you know he might rub people the wrong
way look so no one's going to get along
or not everyone's going to get along
with the Sean Kaiser so I think he might
just have rubbed some teams the wrong
way and I wouldn't be surprised if one
of them might maybe even was as his old
head coach at Notre Dame and obviously
former coaches have have a strong say in
the process as well something happened
there it's like you mentioned it wasn't
on the field and I think if we can
extrapolate those comments it might just
be that some of these teams might be
turned off by that confidence but again
I think back in 2015 DeSean Kaiser the
best quarterback in this class you know
it's interesting to me Josh because you
say you love his comments I would tend
to believe that most teams will look at
this and say why would he say those
things it doesn't help like how does it
help you today I can be a cam newton
brady combo if I were an executive I'd
say all right now we got one other thing
we need to worry about with Kaiser that
he doesn't know that there's no upside
making comments like that then how does
he benefit there's no upside that was
your same reaction right to the myles
garrett comments correct yes about
saying that he's not necessarily the
smartest guy in the draft but he's uh
prayer yeah look I think that these guys
are individuals you know and I kind of
embrace individuality and many times
with these prospects we even know that
they get coached during the interview
process and and just to throw out
cliches and whatever other NFL
quarterbacks or players do in the NFL
right to me I understand that on paper
that might not sound correct it might
not sound preferable but i like when
these guys show a little bit of
personality and we'd absolutely seen in
the past that the NFL is turned off by
that but specifically in kaisers case i
love it because its head coach is not
doing at a college level even though he
should be because i mean that's just
another form of recruiting is adding
players to the NFL no question about
Josh always appreciate the time terrific
stuff thanks so much for coming on cool
thanks man appreciate it there is josh
norris from NBC sports he is there NFL
draft writer the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience